All right,
welcome back to Computer Vision.
This time we're going to start sort of
on some of the small technical details
of doing recognition.
Remember we said that recognition
is mostly going to be some form
of a classification problem,
now we're going to look at some
methods and some representations.
So today we're going to start
with the one we talked about,
supervised classification, and in fact,
almost everything we're going to do is
going to be in the supervised domain.
So in the supervised world, basically
I give you a set of labeled training
examples, and the goal is to
come up with some function, but
if you give it a new example,
it'll generate the correct label.
So using the handwritten digit
recognition as a example, so
here we have some training examples,
right, we've got a bunch of fours and
a bunch of nines, and you'll notice,
they're not, it's not trivial right,
because these, these fours, you know,
could have been a nine, but
no, they're actually fours.
So what I want to do is I want
to come up with a function
such that if I give it some novel input,
I give it something that looks like
this, it's going to say, what?
Is it going to say four or nine?
>> Nine
>> Very good.
Very nine.
Megan's been paying attention.